bis nordamerika dieser alte david bowie
songs fast heute eine globale geteilte
sorge zusammen was nur ist aus den usa
geworden was aus der letzten wahren
supermacht der heimat der freiheit jahr
des glückes selbst fragen die niemand
besser zu beantworten müsste als die
historie in jilib harvard professorin
und edelfeder des magazins new yorker
nicht zuletzt gefeierter autor in einer
geschichte der vereinigten staaten
frauenpower herzlich willkommen in der
alten welt
vielen dank es freut mich hier zu sein
report zu den großen ritualen des
amerikanischen wahlkampfes zählt dass
jeder kandidat und jede kandidatin am
ende der rede sagt und ich glaube dass
die beiden staaten das großartigste land
in der geschichte der menschheit sind
sie sind jetzt keine politikerin sondern
historiker glauben sie das auch
ich denke die usa sind eine äußerst
wichtige nationen mit einer besonderen
geschichte die das weltgeschehen
beeinflusst sind sie die größten
nationen der menschheitsgeschichte
tatsächlich wird das ständig behauptet
und viele die das behaupten glauben noch
fest daran nicht weil die usa fehlerfrei
wären aber sie haben die politischen
voraussetzungen geschaffen um ihre
fehler zu korrigieren
der große bürgerrechtler martin luther
king pflegte zu sagen
das beste an den vereinigten staaten ist
dass sie das schlimmste korrigieren
können und zwar dank unseres politischen
systems
doch auch andere länder haben diese
fähigkeit die größe der usa liegt in den
umständen ihrer gründung in diese dieses
fundament darüber werden wir sprechen in
ihrer mitreißenden geschichte diese
wahrheiten
das ist der vereinigten staaten nähern
sie sich ihrem land ja zunächst nicht
als einen geografischen raum oder als
eine vorliegende nation sondern sie
sprechen von der idee die amerika ist um
was für eine idee handelt es sich da
nations nationen sind fiktionen in einem
gewissen sinn wird eine nation aus den
nachkommen einer gemeinsamen familie
gebildet das ist die historische
biblische definition von nation
nationalstaaten hingegen sind kreationen
der moderne mann ordnet die geschichte
eines volkes geografisch 1
das ist eine gratwanderung es ist
gefährlich denn gewisse leute könnten
vorgeben ursprünglich aus dem land zu
stammen aus imperialistischen motiven
weil sie es erobern möchten die usa
entstanden auf ganz andere weise nämlich
durch eine revolution bei der es darum
ging er sich von einer bestimmten
politischen ordnung zu distanzieren
die gründer waren eine politische
gemeinschaft die sich gewissen ideen und
verpflichtet fühlte das ist in der
unabhängigkeitserklärung festgelegt die
thomas jefferson 1776 schrieb es gibt
drei gründungsideen wir erachten diese
wahrheiten als selbstverständlich dass
alle menschen gleich geschaffen und von
ihrem schöpfer mit gewissen
unveräußerlichen rechten ausgestattet
sind
das ist eine idee das ist nämlich das
wundervolle das sind so heilige setzte
setzte die für die gesamte westliche
welt eine große bedeutung haben und es
darf sie deswegen noch einmal vorlesen
denn dass sie benennen diese wahrheiten
die aus ihrem buch den titel gegeben
haben folgende wahrheiten heißt es in
der unabhängigkeitserklärung von 1776
folgende wahrheiten erachten wir als
selbstverständlich dass alle menschen
gleich geschaffen sind dass sie von
ihrem schöpfer mit gewissen
unveräußerlichen rechten ausgestattet
sind dass dazu leben freiheit und das
streben nach glück gehören das zur
sicherung dieser rechte regierungen
unter den menschen eingerichtet werden
die ihre rechtmäßige macht aus der
zustimmung der regierten hier
wir haben alles erhaben gleichheit
freiheit glücksversprechen demokratische
selbstbestimmung und die sollen
selbstverständlich sein
self evidente wie es dort heißt wenn man
diese sätze hört dann scheint zunächst
alles klar
wenn man dabei ein bisschen darüber
nachdenken kann man sagen diese sätze
sind vieles aber sie sind eines nicht
selbstverständlich ist die
selbstverständlichkeit dran
richtig sie sind nicht
selbstverständlich das ist das seltsame
an der us-politik viele leute denken
diese worte seien irgendwie vom himmel
gefallen
ähnlich wie die zehn gebote auf moses
tafeln was natürlich nicht stimmt
es sind ideen und ideen haben eine
geschichte
ich habe diese ideen ins zentrum meines
buchs gestellt im ersten drittel gehe
ich der frage nach woher diese ideen
kommen und in den beiden anderen
dritteln versuche ich ausgehend von der
voraussetzung die usa seien ein
politisches experiment zu beweisen ob
diese ideen sind
der test ist sind diese ideen
wissenschaftlicher wissen welche
antworten gibt uns die geschichte wir
sehen wie sie sich verbreitet haben
die uno menschenrechtskonvention von
1948 bedient sich einer sehr ähnlichen
sprache und auch viele staaten bauen ihr
selbstverständnis und ihre
menschenrechte darauf aber ich habe viel
zeit investiert um darzulegen dass es
nicht jeffersons ideen waren von john
adams stammt eine berühmte aussage die
nicht in meinem buch steht er war sehr
wütend das ist auch einer dieser mensch
hat ja ein mitbegründer er war wütend
weil seine beteiligung an der
unabhängigkeitserklärung nicht gewürdigt
wurde
und er war auch wütend weil dafür sehr
gelobt wurde
denn albums sagte diese ideen existieren
schon seit langem jefferson hat sie nur
aufgeschrieben zwischen adams und
jefferson herrschte diese berühmte
rivalität
frühere historiker sagten diese ideen
würden von europäischen politischen
philosophen stammen und von jean jacques
rousseau diese ideen wurden in
opposition zu denken wie thomas hobbes
aufgestellt das stimmt die verfasser der
unabhängigkeitserklärung lasen die werke
von john locke
aber ich finde wir müssen schauen warum
diese ideen zur entstehung der
vereinigten staaten geführt haben
eine besorgniserregende tatsache ist
dass die amerikaner welche die
unabhängigkeitserklärung aufsetzen
verwickelt waren in den genozid von
ureinwohnern und in die versklavung von
afrikanern die indigenen und die
afrikanischen sklaven geplagten von
anfang an auf grund von welchem recht
nehmt ihr mir mein land weg meine
souveränität meine arbeit mein glück
mein leben auf welches recht beruft ihr
euch sie versuchten zu verstehen wie
diese leute die tyrannei und diese
formen der grausamkeit rechtfertigen und
gleichzeitig solche ideen von freiheit
souveränität und rechten hoch halten
konnten sogar die gründung selbst so
auffüllen dich sie fand entstammt dieser
erfahrung von großem leid
wir sehen schon diese geschichte ist
auch eine geschichte der widersprüche
und ein gründungs widerspruch haben sie
schon genannt wir werden uns mit den
effekten dieses widerspruch ist auch
noch beschäftigen
aber ganz eindeutig in dieser ursprungs
formulierung gibt es ja schon einen
widerspruch auf denen sie großen wert
legen sie sagen nämlich jefferson
schrieb diese wahrheiten sind heilig und
unbestreitbar und benjamin franklin
änderte das dann er strich das durch und
sagte sie sind selbstverständlich man
kann da ja zwei große tradition sind
eine religiöse herleitung der
menschenrechte
eine aufklärerische philosophische das
sind ja auch zwei stränge die in amerika
ganz eng miteinander verwoben sind
und es gab immer spannungen zwischen
ihnen dass dieser kleine disput weder
franklin noch jefferson war religiös sie
rangen um die beste formulierung
schließlich einigten sie sich nicht von
gott sondern vom schöpfer zu sprechen
was etwas wahres aber was heißt das
schon
sie beschlossen das wort gott in der
verfassung nicht zu verwenden
die intellektuellen die dieses dokument
entwerfen waren also nicht religiös aber
sie lebten in einer sehr religiösen welt
kurz nach der verabschiedung der
unabhängigkeitserklärung gab es zudem
einen religiösen aufschwung mit diesem
phänomen befasste ich mich lange denn
als jefferson schrieb alle menschen sind
gleich geschaffen meinte er wie john
lobb landeigentümer die beschlossen
haben eine regierung zu bilden um ihre
interessen zu wahren
also nicht ohne voraussetzung sondern
durchaus voraussetzung es reich männer
eigentümer gemeint war das verstanden
damals alle so die
unabhängigkeitserklärung wurde 1776
verabschiedet 50 jahre später 1826 wurde
der fünfzigste jahrestag groß gefeiert
es gab paraden und ansprachen man
errichtete monumente veranstaltete ein
riesen tamtam
gleichzeitig erlebten die usa diesen
religiösen aufschwung und viele
evangelikale christen larsen wegen des
jahrestages das dokument das sie vorher
kommt zur kenntnis genommen hatten und
als evangelikale christen verstanden sie
den satz alle menschen sind gleich
geschaffen so dass wir alle gleich sind
vor gott
ob mann oder frau schwarze oder weiße
junge oder alte reiche oder arme im
weiteren sinne also in einen viel
weiteren tief spirituellen sinn
sie interpretierten die
unabhängigkeitserklärung neu und heute
gilt ihre interpretation
sie fügten die idee der gleichheit hinzu
und nutzten die unabhängigkeitserklärung
als argument für die abschaffung der
sklaverei die unabhängigkeitserklärung
macht uns alle frei denn sie erkennt
dass wir vor gott alle gleich sind und
gleiche rechte haben
daher muss die sklaverei sofort
abgeschafft werden
das war eine radikale neuinterpretation
eines 50-jährigen dokuments wohin man
auch sieht und das ist wunderbar zu
lesen ihrer geschichte dieses landes
dass man heute sagt die religiöse recht
ist ein konservatives repressives
element aber es war in großen zeiten
dieses land ist ein progressives
erweitern das element so dass man nicht
sagen könnte diese eine gruppe tut dies
oder jenes sondern sie tut verschiedenes
zu verschiedenen zeiten
sie sprachen davon die usa sind ein
experiment und so als solches wollen sie
es verstehen dass ein experiment das
beispielhaft für die gesamte westliche
welt geht bei experimenten ist es so
wenn sie welche sind weiß man nicht wie
sie ausgehen
sie sind offen zwei thesen zum
experimente usa heute einige sagen
dieses experiment ist in ihrem in seinem
verlauf bedroht und andere sagen dieses
experiment ist schon lange gestorben
es ist schon lange nicht mehr lebendig
es gibt nur noch die rhetorik der
demokratie aber es gibt sie nicht mehr
wirklich welche beiden welche beiden
antworten scheinen plausibel
wir haben zwei stark vereinfachte
historische sichtweisen die zwei hoch
polarisierende politische haltungen ab
während die eine besagt amerika war ein
großartiges experiment das irgendwann
nach vietnam scheiterte deshalb müssen
wir amerika wieder groß machen
nach diesem konservativen verständnis
der amerikanischen geschichte haben die
usa die unrecht
der welt angerichtet die amerikaner
haben nie etwas falsch gemacht
die geschichte der usa ist eine
geschichte der triumphe und wunder
die progressive linke hingegen findet
die usa hätten immer alles falsch
gemacht sein für grausamkeiten und
imperialismus verantwortlich und würden
nun den rechtspopulismus in der welt
verbreiten als wären die usa eine art
infektion auch das ist ein historisches
argument beide sind falsch sie können
nicht richtig sein denn wer sagt alles
sei gut gewesen sieht das schlechte
nicht und wer sagt alles sei schlecht
gewesen sieht das gute nicht
unter anderem schrieb ich das buch um
vorzuschlagen liegen wir mal die
politischen argumente beiseite und
schauen wir was uns die geschichte
erzählt was historische recherchen der
letzten 50 jahre zutage gefördert haben
damit wir die geschichte etwas klarer
sehen dann kann man nicht mehr glauben
es habe diesen moment gegeben nachdem
alles bergab ging oder besser wurde
denn es war immer ein kampf wenn man
anerkennt dass die verfassung mangelhaft
ist und ständig vor allem auch heute
verbessert werden muss
dann hat man einen gesünderen blick auf
die nation als wenn man einer früheren
größe nachtrauert weil die republik ist
eindeutig in gefahr
differenzierung und distanzierung das
sind zwei tugenden die man von
historikern unbedingt erwarten würde und
ein ablehnen von trio fallis tischen
geschichten oder verfalls geschichten
sie versuchen sich da sehr kunstvoll in
der mitte und differenziert zu halten
aber sie haben dieses buch geschrieben
als obama noch präsident war und sie
haben es abgeschlossen als donald trump
präsident wurde so viel distanz und
differenzierung traurig selbst ihnen
nicht zu dass sie sagen das hat
ich gar nicht beeinflusst das hat auch
meine sicht auf die vereinigten staaten
nicht beeinflusst das ist interessant
denn ich schrieb mehr als die hälfte
meines buchs vor trance war ich begann
2014 zu schreiben und war 2016 fertig
ich brauchte rund drei jahre dafür
ich hatte einen entwurf und wusste genau
was war geschehen war
die historiker schreiben nicht gern über
die gegenwart weil wir nicht wissen was
wir dazu sagen sollen
niemand kann erklären was gerade
passiert und ich wollte mit 2009
abschließen
einerseits weil sich obama den usa und
der welt als brücke zwischen diesen
beiden positionen präsentiert
ich bin weder der eine noch der andere
ich bin der sohn einer weißen frau aus
kansas und eines schwarzen mannes aus
kenia und ich bin die brücke zwischen
diesen beiden positionen
er wollte den kompromiss in seiner
person verkörpert er wollte die brücke
sein
das fand ich sehr schön
es funktionierte nicht war aber eine
schöne idee seine wahl war daher ein
guter abschluss für mein buch den
amerikanern der ganzen welt gefiel
obamas haltung sie schien wunderbar dann
wurde trump gewählt und ich musste die
nächsten acht jahre anhängen und bis zum
wahltag 2016 schreiben ich veränderte
nichts an den vorherigen kapiteln des
buches aber erstaunlicherweise fragen
die leser wie konnten sie 1000 seitiges
buch schreiben das trump so schnell
erklärt ich antwortete ich habe kein
1000 seitiges buch geschrieben um trump
zu erklären
ich wollte damit obama erklären und dann
wurde trump gewählt es ist die gleiche
geschichte
wir meinen die beiden positionen seien
getrennt aber es ist das gleiche land
dass beide strömungen produziert
sie sprachen von der brückenbauer wenn
man eine brücke bauen muss hat man ja
immer zwei teile
trump marken und viele seiner wehr ist
kein brückenbauer er ist jemand der
diese beiden camps die verschiedenartig
gestaltet sind gegeneinander ausspielt
der ideengeschichte lag lena hat auch
eine eigene idee zu zwei großen
revolutionen zu zwei großen camps
schauen wir uns mal an als er über die
usa derzeit sagt in den usa finden zwei
revolutionen gleichzeitig statt
einerseits die politische revolution die
von rechts und unten kommt und
populistisch ist
gleichzeitig ist eine kulturelle
revolution in gang nämlich dass menschen
anerkennung und akzeptanz in der
gesellschaft brauchen die veränderungen
allein während meiner lebenszeit sind
außergewöhnlich vor 10 oder 15 jahren
nahm niemand gleichgeschlechtliche ehen
ernst das ist eine gewaltige veränderung
in der gesellschaft weltweit solche
errungenschaften sind gut aber diese
revolution wird von kulturellen eliten
geführt sie kommt nicht von unten und
sie ist nicht demokratisch denn niemand
kann darüber abstimmen
aber hollywood die presse die
bildungsinstitutionen sind sich einig
dass diese neuen werte verbreitet werden
müssen das ist gut das problem ist wenn
alle energie in diese kulturelle
revolution gesteckt wird kümmert man
sich nicht mehr um reale konkrete macht
wenn sie außerdem nur über solche
kulturellen dinge sprechen und darüber
dass diese menschen ausgegrenzt werden
bekommt die öffentlichkeit von ihrer
partei oder politischen gruppierung den
eindruck sie würden sich nur um diese
leute und nicht um die ganze nation und
um menschen kümmern die nicht zu diesen
gruppierungen gehören
man muss also eine tragische
entscheidung treffen bezüglich energie
und rhetorik ich versuche das noch mal
ein bisschen enger zusammen zu fassen
was mag lena sagt ist
dass eine gewisse form von
identitätspolitik die sich um
minderheitenrechte kümmerte von eliten
betrieben wurde und dass dabei ein
großteil des landes nicht bedacht nicht
wahrgenommen wurde und dieser teil des
landes rebelliert jetzt in einer form
von populistischen strömungen donald
trump hervorgebracht hat das ist eine
diagnose die sie für richtig halten
nein das glaube ich noch es gibt ein
wahres element doch lena gewichtet die
vorherrschaft des sogenannten kultur
kriegs in unserer heutigen gesellschaft
zu stark der kultur krieg der 90er jahre
führte ganz klar die politische spaltung
der usa doch heute streiten die
amerikaner nicht darüber empirisch ist
das ziemlich gut belegt es gibt in den
usa die interessante bewegung morent
kommen mir gemeinsam ist das ist ein
meinungsumfrage institut das bei seinen
umfragen sehr interessante methoden
anwendet so hat es herausgefunden wenn
man die leute fragt was sind die träger
bezüglich integration mauerbau die
abtreibung las ich vor erstmal seite
aber vielleicht transgender rechte diese
dinge halten wir für kulturell explosiv
wenn man nicht versucht durch die
formulierung der frage eine partei
orientierte reaktion zu provozieren
sondern fragt finden sie es wichtig dass
die menschen ein zugehörigkeitsgefühl
entwickeln wenn sie in die usa kommen
statt zu fragen sollen wir flüchtlinge
unterbringen oder eine andere frage die
eine sofortige reaktion provoziert dann
findet man eine recht breite zustimmung
zu vielen dingen viel mehr als man
erwartet wenn man mark lilla liest ich
denke es passiert leicht dass die elite
kultur kriege falsch einschätzt
es gibt tiefe spaltungen und die sind
extrem gefährlich
ich gehe mit lila einig dass die
demokraten wichtige politische
prioritäten nicht gesetzt haben darüber
schreibe ich auch ich finde die
demokratische partei sucht an den
falschen orten nach geld und setzt
falsche prioritäten
aber das ist schon sehr lange der fall
schon vor hillary clinton
ich würde sagen 2016 waren die
demokraten ein desaster und sie hatten
eine desaströse
präsidentschaftskandidatin die einen
schlechten wahlkampf führte das ist die
offensichtliche erklärung führt donald
trumps erfolg also wichtig so richtig
ein anderer kandidat oszilliere clinton
hätte thromben nicht möglich werden
lassen
aus ihrer sicht ja ja ich finde die
demokraten hätten das feld für einen
richtigen wettbewerb öffnen sollen dann
hätten wir bessere kandidatin gekürt
es bringt mich auf die palme dass
hillary clinton kandidiert hat aber was
ich als gefährlich erachtet und ich gehe
mit magna einig wie schlimm die dinge
sind aber ich bin uneinig mit ihm
darüber was daran schlimm ist wie ich im
buch argumentiere wurden die spaltungen
in den usa in den 19 70er und 80er
jahren bewusst geschaffen von
parteistrategen welche die republikaner
auf die rechte seite und die demokraten
auf die linke seite bringen wollten
und sie taten das und sie würden sagen
das ist meine strategie des teile und
herrsche schaffe teilung und versuche
die teilung für dich zu nutzen das war
die strategie der siebziger und
achtziger jahre
ja wenn auch nicht von allen aber von
schlüssel strategen in beiden parteien
und das taten sie anhand der waffen und
abtreibungsfrage denn beides sind
schwache verfassungsrechtliche argumente
aus unterschiedlichen gründen
also das heißt sie sind in der
verfassung selbst nicht eindeutig
geklärt die auslegung des zweiten
zusatzartikel der verfassung steht auf
sehr schwachen füßen und bezüglich der
abtreibung wird in der verfassung mit
dem recht auf privatsphäre argumentiert
dass aber nirgendwo spezifiziert
man kann es also immer wieder legen das
recht auf abtreibung das recht auf
privatsphäre das recht eine waffe zu
tragen gelten als rechte können aber
abgesprochen werden weil sie nicht stark
genug in der verfassung verankert sind
und dabei geht es um leben und tod
die parteistrategen schufen so etwas wie
eine maschine um die menschen zu
entzweien
indem sie sagten wenn ihr der linken
angehört
wenn man ein raster macht und waffen und
abschreibung auf die senkrechte achse
und mord und freiheit auf die waagrechte
achse setzt stehen für die linken waffen
für mord und abtreibung für freiheit
während für die richten waffen für
freiheit und abtreibung für mord stehen
also geht es bei allem worüber sie
abstimmen um freiheit oder um mord so
lud man wählt nicht eine kandidatin weil
man findet sie habe eine gute agenda
bezüglich erziehungsfragen oder einen
kandidaten weil er gute ansätze für die
bekämpfung der staatsverschuldung zeigt
man wählt jemanden aufgrund von
kriterien wie mord oder freiheit so
polarisierend formulierten die parteien
ihre botschaften an die bevölkerung
das ist faszinierend weil das fängt ja
fast so wie ein handbuch von einigen
strategen die sagen wir haben ja eine
situation es gibt ein gebiet von themen
die konstitutionell nicht klar sind so
lange unklarheit herrscht ist das gut
wir polarisieren diese unklarheit und so
polarisieren wir den diskurs und am ende
sind wir die starken klingt ja sehr
strategisch sehr kalt und übrigens auch
sehr republik feindlich letztlich es ist
irgendwie unheimlich und man sieht wie
es passiert 1971 bevor die national
rifle association die gewähr vereinigung
ein wichtiger politischer faktor war
interviewte ich sie würden zum beispiel
sagen diese waffen organisation die die
waffen besitze das ist eine dieser
organisation die das gesehen hat und die
ist klein instrumentalisiert hat während
er noch andere spieler
sie sahen dass in einem bundesstaat über
die verschärfung der waffenkontrolle
abgestimmt wurde
ich glaube es war in maryland und sie
realisierten wie viele leute an die urne
gingen die republikaner sahen dass
männer in pick ups zu den wahllokalen
fanden die seit jahren nicht mehr
abgestimmt hatten
denn sie wollten nicht verlieren sie
waren jäger und waren sehr besorgt wegen
der abstimmung realisierten die
republikaner
wir können leute an die ohne bringen die
normalerweise nicht abstimmen
es ist ein sehr emotionales thema für
viele ist es sehr persönlich
die abtreibungsfrage ist anders da
reagierten viele auf eine kampagne der
rechten welche die abtreibungs rechte
einschränken wollten
und doch ist es ein ähnliches thema denn
es trifft die menschen tief zurück zumal
das gestein den 70er und 80er jahren als
viele weiße frauen von der
republikanischen zur demokratischen
partei wechselten und viele weiße männer
von der demokratischen zur
republikanischen partei ja sie
wechselten die partei und es gab einen
fantastischen wortwechsel zwischen einem
republikanischen und einem
demokratischen partei strategen
das war glaube ich 1982 der demokrat
sagte ihr gebt uns an der weißen frauen
mit eurer anti abtreibungs kampagne und
der republikaner sagte aber ihr gebt uns
alle weißen männer das ist der bessere
deal
sie waren sehr offen wenn's wirklich
beim quartett spielen dass man so sagt
trümpfe gegeneinander genau wie figuren
in einem schachspiel das wurde also
absichtlich und für kurzsichtige
politische zwecke missbraucht
seither sind jedoch das internet und vor
allem die sozialen medien hinzugekommen
die prädestiniert sind dafür die user
auszuwählen und ihnen nur bestimmte
nachrichten zukommen zu lassen
es ist sehr schwierig das in den griff
zu bekommen es wurde von menschen
geschaffen funktioniert jetzt dabei
automatisch das ist faszinierend zu
hören und an erklärung die
wahrscheinlich viel überzeugungskraft
hat aber wenn man als historiker einen
schritt zurücktritt könnte man ja sagen
diese teilung der vereinigten staaten
die ist von der geburt an da dieses land
musste nicht erst gezahlt werden das war
immer schon ein geteiltes land
man könnte sagen es beruht auf einem
genozid zunächst es hatte die sklaverei
als bedingung möglichkeiten es führte zu
einem bürgerkrieg mit regionalen
differenzen die wir heute noch sehen so
faszinierende geschichte finde die idee
dass die vereinigten staaten erst seit
kurzem geteilte staaten sind ist die
historisch nicht auch angreifbar
das sehe ich wie folgt man kann sich
vorstellen es hätte in den usa seit 1790
immer nur zwei parteien gegeben
so haben sich zwar verändert aber es
waren immer nur zwei natürlich es dann
die distanz zwischen den beiden manchmal
größer und manchmal kleiner
aber ich finde es passender von drei
parteien zu sprechen
einzig das eine unsichtbar ist aber sie
bestimmt die beziehung der anderen
beiden parteien zueinander
anders gesagt 1860 zur zeit des
bürgerkriegs wurden vier millionen
afroamerikaner als sklaven gehalten
sie bildeten keine politische partei
denn sie durften nicht wählen und hatten
keinerlei macht aber wenn man unter
partei eine gruppe mit einer gemeinsamen
politischen agenda versteht dann gibt es
keine einheitliche reporter als die von
menschen die gefangen gehalten werden
sie wollen sich emanzipieren und sie
wollen richtet ihr eigenes grundstück
sie hatten sehr einheitliche
parteipositionen trotz ihrer
emanzipation nach der aufhebung der
rassengesetze konnten die afroamerikaner
erst 1965 wählen gehen
ich denke diese partei gab es immer
diese gruppe von menschen ohne
politische macht deren hauptziel
politische gleichstellung ist und diese
gruppe bestimmt seit jeher die beziehung
zwischen den anderen beiden parteien
es gibt eine wunderbare
veranschaulichung ein gemälde dass diese
dritte partei auch zeigt nämlich ein
gemälde von 848 über den eine nachricht
aus dem krieg gegen mexiko damals
geführt wurde und vielleicht künstlers
erklären was dort geschieht und wo die
dritte unsichtbare partei von der sie
sprechen zu sehen wäre ja ich liebe
dieses gemälde von 1848 es heißt kriegs
nachrichten aus mexiko mexiko 1848
endete der krieg zwischen den usa und
mexiko durch den die usa große gebiete
mexikos annektiert hatten
es ist eine allegorie für die usa
betitelt als das amerikanische hotel mit
dem adler über dem eingangsportal und
ein lobgesang auf die amerikanische
demokratie den 1848 kunden in den usa
anders als in der ganzen westlichen welt
alle weisen männer wählen
zum ersten mal in der us geschichte die
weisen männer vor dem eingang die wir
uns alle ziemlich gleich aussehen stehen
eigentlich für die unterschiedlichkeit
der us bevölkerung
denn da sieht man einen reichen mann und
einen der weniger reich wird eine alten
und einen jungen und einen der aussieht
wie ein einwanderer sozialen schichten
jemand aus der stadt und jemand vom land
ein einwanderer der steuern bezahlte
konnte auch wählen
es ist als eine darstellung der
demokratie und alle sind wie man das von
bürgern erwartet damit beschäftigt die
zeitung zu lesen und sie scheinen auch
über die kriegs nachrichten aus mexiko
zu diskutieren
einerseits zelebriert der mann also die
demokratie und die ausweitung der
stimmberechtigung aber es ist auch ein
sehr heimtückisches bild am eingang
szene auf der linken seite sieht man zb
dass das hotel am zerfallen ist
es ist also keine so stabile demokratie
man merkt etwas stimmt nicht mit diesem
amerikanischen hotel und ganz besonders
gibt es dort am rande zwei gruppen die
teil dieser unsichtbaren partei sind
wenn man jetzt die sklaven das sind vier
millionen aber es gibt ja noch eine frau
genau sie ist ganz rechts im bild man
sieht sie kaum sie ist fast unsichtbar
eine weiße frau die unter dem vordach
nichts zu suchen hat und nicht wählen
kann
wenn auch 1848 die frauen in den usa
erstmals das wahlrecht forderten sie
hört auch zu und weiß dass diese
nachrichten sie betreffen
und wie sie gesagt haben sitzt auf den
treppenstufen ein afroamerikaner mit
einem vermummten kind wohl sein sohn
womit angedeutet wird dass es sklaven
sind auch sie sind nicht erwünscht unter
dem vordach aber sie wissen dass diese
nachrichten sie mir als alle anderen
wird
treffen werden und was so stark ist die
beiden sind rot weiß und blau gekleidet
so wunderbar zu sehen wie wie sie das
begeistert diese darstellung von 1848
weil das ja auch strukturelle verhältnis
sind die bis heute andauern
keinem der heute die usa besucht kann
entgehen dass diese strukturelle
benachteiligung der schwarzen
bevölkerung an dauert es ist auf jeder
straße in ihrem supermarkt mit händen zu
greifen
richtig natürlich dauert es fort aber
bei uns in den usa gibt es kein
bewusstsein dafür wie lange das schon
andauert bei uns gilt traditionell jeder
tag ist eine neue chance es gibt keine
vergangenheit
charakteristisch für amerika ist wir
beginnen jeden tag neu mann konfrontiert
sich nur widerwillig mit der
vergangenheit ein grund für die tram
wahl als gegenreaktion ist dass viele
amerikaner meinten dank obamas
präsidentschaft gäbe es kein rassen
probleme sie wünschten aufrichtig dass
das problem gelöst wäre die weißen
fanden können wir das nun zu den akten
legen bis es war wirklich hart und
offensichtlich schrecklich aber nehmen
sie an es sei vorbei lassen wir es
hinter uns
doch das war nicht der fall also eine
falsche sicherheit dass ein kapitel
geschlossen sein möge das aber gar nicht
geschlossen war sondern wir eine offene
wunde weiter aus entstehen und 2014 kurz
nachdem obama seine zweite amtszeit
antritt startete die akws maitre
bewegungen und das ist eine bewegung
muss man sagen die sich gegen
polizeigewalt struktureller art gegen
schwarze mitbürger besonders richtet
richtig sie prangert auch die
routinierte polizeigewalt gegen schwarze
an nicht nur die morde die gefilmt
wurden sondern die täglichen schikanen
kritisiert wird zudem die hohe zahl der
inhaftierten afro und latino amerikaner
wohl die weltweit höchste zeit
diese bewegung macht auf diese
ungerechtigkeiten aufmerksam
ich habe den eindruck viele weiße
amerikaner dachten wir haben durch grad
obama wiedergewählt sind damit dieser
diskussion nicht durch ich denke das hat
einige bilder zu trump hingezogen
denn das war ein wichtiger bestandteil
seiner botschaft schuld daran ist nicht
die bled lifes major bewegung sie hat
eine wichtige aufgabe aber gezeigt dass
dieses thema noch eine politische
valencia hat dass man damit arbeiten
kann und dass es waren entscheiden kann
ein weiteres großes trimmen sie sind
historikerin eine der berühmtesten
gefeierten historien ihres landes ist
natürlich die rolle der frauen in dem
was wir geschichte nennen
geschichte wird von männern geschrieben
das ist insbesondere auch für die
geschichte der vereinigten staaten
scheinbar war wie haben sie das
bedürfnis den den drang und auch die
wichtigkeit frauen in ihrer rolle für
die entwicklung des landes darstellbar
werden zu lassen
wie sind sie das angegangen als junge
frau ging ich an die universität weil
ich frauen geschichte studieren wollte
es war in den 19 80er und frühen 90er
jahren als die studiengänge explodierten
die sich mit frauen und genderfragen
gefassten und ich habe tiere ich diese
lebensläufe zu entdecken
die nie in den geschichtsbüchern
vorkamen durchgelesen hatte also war das
für sie hat sich das bild was ich will
über frauen schreiben da deswegen werde
ich es tue ritterin dafür der hauptgrund
warum ich historikerin werden wollte und
dann ging ich an die universität und
realisierte dass dort eine unglaubliche
forschung im gange war
aber die buchläden verkauften immer noch
titel wie die größe von davos mit großer
die tragödie des bürgerkriegs woodrow
wilson und der völkerbund und es schien
als würde niemand lesen was die
forschung gerade entdeckte auch
ethnische studien studien über
homosexualität und afroamerikanische
studien aber vor allem studien über
frauen niemand leisten
dann nicht an die öffentlichkeit das
störte mich sehr
trotzdem studierte ich nicht
frauengeschichte ich wurde politischer
historikerin habe mich aber auch
intensiv mit frauen geschichte befasst
und was ich mit meinem buch aufzeigen
wollte war nicht einfach eine auflistung
der präsidentin
da war george washington dann kam john
adams dann thomas jefferson dann james
madison
das ist die us geschichte stark
personalisierte natürlich richtig und
dann widmen wir einen kleinen paragrafen
den frauen und einen anderen der
sklaverei als ob sie nichts heil der
politischen geschichte wären
ich beschloss ein buch zu schreiben das
klarmacht dass es immer frauen gegeben
hat und das bilden frauen politisch
aktiv waren auch als man ihnen das
wahlrecht verweigert
ich fand es interessant dass
systematisch zu tun denn ich stieß auf
dinge die ich nie zuvor gesehen hatte
ich dachte zum beispiel darüber nach was
geschah gerade weil frauen das wahlrecht
nicht bekam weiße frauen konnten erst
1920 wählen schwarze frauen erst 1965 es
dauerte nach der gründung der usa ein
gutes halbes jahrhundert bis frauen
wählen konnten
trotzdem haben die frauen die politik
stark beeinflusst und sie taten das wie
machen sie das das würde mich
interessieren nur wenn sie wählen können
und ich nicht ich aber etwas ändern
möchte muss ich versuchen sie zu
überzeugen so zu wählen dass meine
interessen berücksichtigt werden frauen
sagen
tatsache ist wir sind besser als er
männer frauen sind männern moralisch
überlegen moralische fragen sollte man
uns stellen weil wir bescheid wissen und
sagen können wie man wählen soll
wir gehen auf die straße und zeigen euch
das bei moralischen fragen die frauen am
besten bescheid wissen müssen sie das
klingt so nach einer analyse die
friedrich nietzsche mal getroffen hat
wenn man keine macht hat versetzt man
sich moralischen eine bessere position
damit man die macht bekommen können dass
die sklaven moral
würden sie sagen dass das die weise ist
in der frauenpolitik machen die nicht
wählen dürfen
ja genau sie entwickeln und
perfektionieren
dass ich den weiblichen moralischen
kreuzzug nenne so kämpfen sie für die
abschaffung der sklaverei und dafür dass
weniger alkohol getrunken wird
sie kämpfen für den frieden sie werden
populistin in die lebens rechts bewegung
ist ein kreuzzug wie auch die metro
bewegung den frauen sind politisch immer
noch nicht gleichberechtigt
das ist ja ein sagen wir mal gelinde
gesagt kontroverser standpunkt dass man
sagt das mit uhu hat es letztlich einen
machtkampf der mit den mitteln der
moralität geführt wird
ja ja ich glaube sie gehört zur
tradition der moralischen kreuzzüge und
ich denke das stellt ein problem dar
unser politisches system versucht den
politischen diskurs vor religiösem
fanatismus zu schützen wenn sie und ich
anderer meinung sind und ich das was sie
sagen blasphemisch finde ist es eine
religiöse frage wenn ich mich dann im
führe das können sie nicht sagen ohne in
die hölle zu kommen haben wir keine
politische diskussion mehr
wir verstehen einander nicht mehr das
war in der geschichte der usa oftmals
ein problem
moralische argumente können auch
befreiend sein denn die
bürgerrechtsbewegung ist auch ein
moralischer kreuzzug
er wurde vor allem von christlich
evangelikalen geführt die meisten waren
baptisten martin luther king war
prediger und seine politischen reden
waren großenteils predigten
es ist eine moralische bewegung sie ist
wichtig und erfolgreich
nicht alle moralischen bewegungen sind
schlecht aber generell ist es
schwieriger wenn eine politische
gemeinschaft die wahlberechtigt ist sich
moralisch engagiert was bei diesen
moralischen kreuzzügen wie sie das jetzt
nennen auffällt ist die haben heute
etwas besonders die haben ein herz
und sie werden von der usa über die
ganze welt verbreitet woran man sehen
kann dass die usa immer noch ein es ist
eine moralische supermacht sie es in der
lage diese moralischen anliegen zu
anliegen der ganzen welt werden zu
lassen
andererseits muss man sagen sie war auch
sehr lange eine moralische supermacht
weil sie für diese ideen weltweit stand
das ist doch auch etwas was wir die
letzten jahre gerade gesehen haben die
moralische supermacht usa hat jede
glaubwürdigkeit man könnte sogar sagen
fast jeden willen verloren diese
wahrheiten global zu verteidigen
[Musik]
doch es ist wichtig an die macht zu
denken die andere staaten über die usa
und ihre möglichkeiten haben in der welt
etwas zu bewirken
ihre frage betrifft den jetzigen
präsidenten
aber ich möchte noch etwas zur
bürgerrechtsbewegung der 1950 er jahre
sagen es gab jahrelange sitzblockaden
und proteste politische und juristische
strategien der nationalen organisation
zur förderung fähiger menschen
der ausgeklügelte politische juristische
und kulturelle kampf für gleiche
bürgerrechte dauerte sehr lange und in
den 1950 er jahren verbuchte er endlich
erste erfolge grund dafür war dass die
usa nach 1949 in den kalten krieg
eintraten und harry truman sagte wir
sind die anführer der freien feld wir
sind die anführer der freien welt und
werden den totalitarismus in jeder form
bekämpfen da fragten die sowjets ihr
seid frei
was sollen dann die rassengesetze wir
erzählen in der zeitung
da die geschichten aller schwarzen die
von der polizei zusammengeschlagen
wurden und dann die lynchmorden wird bei
euch immer noch gelyncht
was ist mit der einkommensungleichheit
aufgrund der rasse die sowjets konnten
über viele vorkommnisse in den usa
berichten die im widerspruch standen zu
der ganzen freiheit rhetorik und sogar
in der truman administration sagte man
sich wenn wir den kalten krieg gewinnen
wollen müssen wir dieses problem lösen
und die anführer der
bürgerrechtsbewegung triumphierten
wir werden davon profitieren denn das
zerstört die moralische autorität der
usa weltweit steht als heuchler wo zu
sorgen
ja die anführer der bürgerrechtsbewegung
wussten
der moment zum handeln war gekommen sie
konnten endlich mit erfolgen rechnen
truman überzeugt er eine große
kommission die bürgerrechte zu studieren
und zumindest legal die rassentrennung
in der schulbildung aufzuheben
das fernsehen begann über die
bürgerrechtsbewegung zu berichten
und bevor man sich versah wurde sie teil
der großen freiheit der usa und das
gesicht ihrer moralischen
vormachtstellung
da war dann dreht sich das und so kommt
politischer wandel auch zustande durch
moralischen druck
es gibt jetzt eine situation die für
dieses land dass sich selbst für das
größte und erfolgreichste aus guten
gründen der welt hält denn neu ist diese
amerikanische exzeptionell ismus
orientiert sich noch es gibt neue große
supermächte wie china es gibt die
kränkung dass man diese welt nicht mehr
in dieser weise beherrschen kann
und jetzt kann man ja sagen es könnten
zwei psychologische effekte eintreten
zum einen eine narzisstische kränkung
wir sind das nicht mehr das wort
aggression
zum anderen könnte man sagen eine
entspannung wir müssen das nicht mehr
sein wir können uns aus dieser
privilegierten situation zurückziehen
und entspannt haben unsere eigenen dinge
kümmern
sehen sie da auch eine deutung
möglichkeit für die politik derzeit
zwischen aggressiver kränkung und
entspannung
nehmen sie zum beispiel den höhepunkt
des britischen reichs
damals meinten die briten sie seien die
herrscher der welt und fanden was
großartig
doch jetzt sind sie nur noch briten eine
zeitlang war ist für sie ganz gut nicht
mehr groß briten sondern nur noch bringt
nun zu sein
dann plötzlich war es nicht mehr sie
realisierten wenn wir nicht mehr das
größte reich sind sind wir nur eine
insel
sie verfielen dem isolationismus das
gleiche zeigt sich verzögert mit dem
zerfall des amerikanischen jahrhunderts
denn es geht dem ende entgegen das
britische reich endete vor einiger zeit
es war eine vorschau von dem was nun in
den usa geschätzt zuerst fanden die
briten es ist okay dass das britische
reich nicht mehr existiert es ist sogar
besser denn imperialismus ist etwas
schreckliches
aber es ist weniger okay nicht mehr die
vormachtstellung des amerikanischen
jahrhunderts zu genießen denn anders als
das britische reich repräsentiert das
amerikanische jahrhundert die hoch
haltung und weltweite verbreitung der
liberalen demokratie
ich höre ihre zuhörer ausrufen was ist
mit vietnam und mit button natürlich
trotzdem lässt sich behaupten dass es
eine vision ist eine globale vision die
erfolgreiche die selbstbestimmung für
die menschen weltweit ins zentrum
stellte und die nationen beschützte die
liberale demokratien werden wollten
vielleicht kommen wir zu dem letzten
großen thema nämlich das utopische
potenzial der usa sie sprach etwas davon
da gab es eine vision die für die ganze
welt verbindlich wurde 1989 ist ja nicht
nur die mauer gefallen sondern das
internet bekannt sich zu entwickeln das
war ein neuer utopischer raum der von
den usa vom silicon valley von
kalifornien aus
mit geradezu fantastischen
versprechungen auftrat demokratisierung
die zentralisierung vernunft gebrauchen
neuer form wenn man ihre geschichte
liest
hört man gelinde gesagt eine gewisse
skepsis bezüglich des utopischen
potenzials der digitalen revolution
heraus ich habe meine skepsis
zurückhaltend formuliert norden auf
diese jahre und der aufstieg der silicon
valley wurden noch nicht genug erforscht
berichtete die das historisch beleuchten
kommen erst heraus ein wichtiges
argument ist der wechsel von der ära der
gigantischen raumfüllend ibm-computer
zur ära der persönlichen computer von
apple in den 1960 er jahren
repräsentiert die ibm für die radikalen
studenten alles tyrannische das große
business der militärisch industrielle
komplex viele diese innovation sind ja
militärische innovation zunächst gewesen
genau es kann also massive kritik an den
großen technischen konzern das gehörte
zur opposition gegen den vietnamkrieg zu
den studenten bewegungen und als diese
radikalen studenten fülle von der
universität berkeley ihr studium
abgeschlossen und selber in der
technologiebranche zu arbeiten begannen
brachten sie ihre linke gesinnung in
diese welt und sie wollten dem
persönlichen computer
er sollte sie befreien und wie eine gute
drucker wirken
man konnte damit sein eigenes ding
durchziehen einen trip machen er
erlaubte er die selbstverwirklichung
wird ja oft übersehen dass es diese
kontinuität zwischen der hippiekultur
und dem diktat dass wir heute sehen und
silicon valley kippt das sind eigentlich
die gleichen menschen die diese version
diese vision der selbstbefreiung in die
welt dann realisierten diese hippies
welche die großen industriellen und
militärischen computer verabscheuten und
den persönlichen computer als vehikel
für ihre befreiung sein
dass die technologie für die vernetzung
von computern im anmarsch war und sie
beteiligten sich daran
sie hatten diese hippie vision der welt
harmonie wir sitzen alle ums lagerfeuer
halten uns an den händen und lieben
einander denn das einzige was wir
brauchten ist verbindung
das alter des digitalen was soll man es
so zu sagen ich mache mich lustig
darüber war es dumm ist und weil sich
diese leute nicht damit
auseinandersetzen wie
kommunikationsformen funktionieren und
was für folgen sie haben doch darüber
wissen wir tatsächlich in den 90er
jahren sollten diese hippies die regeln
fürs internet auf stelle aus dem
militärischen internet wurde ein
internet das für alle kommerziell
zugänglich war und aufgrund ihrer
politischen einstellung sie waren alle
libertär fast anarchistisch wollten sie
keine regeln
wir haben in den usa vorschriften für
das fernsehen das radio und die presse
eine reihe von gesetzen
doch in der verordnung zum internet die
vom kongress 1996 verabschiedet wurde
fehlten diese früheren hippies fest es
gibt keine vorschriften
das ist ja ganz interessant da schon die
deregulierung die man normal also dem
neoliberalismus verwendet auch die
deregulierung war die diese hippie
communitys für sich selbst beanspruchen
ein großer effekt und mir scheint dass
es ein neuer schwerpunkt ihrer arbeit
ist dass daraus für eine demokratie auch
etwas folgt ein neues herrschaftsmodell
zieht ein dass der daten wie sie sagen
gegenüber den fakten die quantifizierung
über die qualitative beurteilung ist das
die größte bedrohung diese derzeit sehen
diese veränderungen in der struktur
einer gesellschaft das lege ich im buch
ein wenig da arbeite er war erst jetzt
vertieft dabei denn ich finde es wichtig
diese veränderungen benennen zu können
ich habe erst begonnen darüber
nachzudenken und zu schreiben
in der mittelalterlichen welt konnten
gewöhnliche menschen nicht viel wissen
sie konnten nicht lesen das meiste was
passierte war nur gott bekannt
es war ein geheimnis sogar wie das
getreide wuchs man wusste dass der regen
half aber man musste zu gott beten
warum verlor eine frau ihr baby das war
ein geheimnis dass nur gott kannte was
geschieht nach dem tod wo kommen die
babys her wer hat diesen mann getötet
nur gott wusste es es war ein zeitalter
der geheimnisse darauf folgte das
zeitalter der fakten mit der
wissenschaftlichen revolution und den
geschworenengerichten die westliche
kultur beschloss es gebe elementare
wissens einheiten die man beobachten
können
wenn ich dieses wasser verschüttet sehen
wir dass beide und es ist somit eine
tatsache ein beobachtetes ereignis aber
hier komplizierter gesellschaften wurden
und über die stunts zu kommunizieren
versuchten desto nützlicher chinas dinge
quantitativ zu beurteilen zu fragen
unter welcher bedingung wird dieses glas
wasser umkippen wenn ich das tausendmal
hier tue und sie in berlin und ich ihnen
einen brief schicken können wir nur
mährisch damit arbeiten und eine theorie
aufstellen wann jemand ein glas wasser
verschüttet so wechselten wir ins
zeitalter der zahlen und momentan sind
wir im die daten zeitalters das ist auch
ein zeitalter der geheimnisse denn die
leute glauben heute nur was die computer
wissen so google nimmt die position
stellen die gott formats hatte vom
mysterium zum faktum zum daten wissen
dass dann eher die maschinen haben und
nicht mehr so sehr die menschen ja und
es gibt diese art priester wie ihn und
maske und andere silicon valley figuren
sie lassen sich feiern als wären sie
priester und sie sagen nur sie hätten
das know-how nur sie könnten die
maschinen mit diesem magischen wörtern
füttern
ich habe großen respekt für die
wissenschaft und technologie die
dahinter steckt aber es lohnt sich den
schieren betrug zu sehen denn das meiste
darstellt denn es hat so großen einfluss
auf das zusammenleben der menschen
demokratischen system da schreien sie
wirklich an einem großen neuen thema
dran zu sein
ihr buch endet mit einer wunderbaren
metapher sie sagen die usa wie ein
schiff und wir müssen eine neue tugend
erlernen die sie navigating beide stars
nennen sich nach den sternen zu richten
in diesem ziel diese tugend zu erwerben
was hinter die dinge die sie ihren
studenten oder ihren lesern mitgeben
wollten was muss anerkennen der nach den
sternen sich ausrichtet viel zeit
verwende ich darauf meine studenten
bewusst zu machen wie sie etwas lernen
können
ich habe den eindruck in unserer zeit
bringt man jungen menschen auf das
gegenteil bei man gibt ihnen ein buch
oder einen artikel zu lesen und dann
wollen sie dir zeigen wie voreingenommen
der autor ist oder was sie über seine
politischen aktivitäten herausgefunden
haben oder sie sagen die vom autor
verwendeten statistiken seien müll
sie sagen dir alles was man beim lesen
des artikels nicht erfährt sie spielen
das spiel finde den schwarzen fleck
darin sind die alle sehr gut alles ist
gefegt wir wissen sehr gut was falsch
ist eine politische kandidatin sagt
etwas
sie liegt aber kultivierung des
misstrauens würden sie sagen
richtig so deshalb sage ich ihnen wir
haben alle den selben artikel gelesen
ich garantiere euch ihr habt etwas
erfahren dass ihr noch nicht gewusst hat
was habt ihr daraus gelernt
das können wir nicht oft genug tun
in einer gruppe zum beispiel in einem 15
köpfigen seminar haben wir vielleicht
nicht alle das gleiche gelernt
vielleicht ziehen wir uns nicht einig
was man daraus lernen kann
aber wir können festlegen dass man in
einer gemeinschaft etwas lernen kann
das tut ja fast wie eine selbstanklage
der akademischen kultur wir haben zu
lange die falschen tugenden gelehrt und
wir müssen andere tun gelernt zum
beispiel schreiben so dass menschen es
verstehen und lesen wollen so wie sie
das tun
höhere bildung ist eine noble arbeit
ich will mich nicht auf einen sockel
stellen aber leute die studenten den
ganzen tag unterrichten indoktrinieren
ihre kinder
mit der eigenen ideologie und
praktizieren keine rechts verdrehung es
ist harte arbeit die sehr schlecht
bezahlt wird und kein hohes ansehen
genießt
ich will höhere bildung nicht schlecht
reden
doch in einem weiteren sinne hat die
postmoderne viel daran gesetzt und
einzutrichtern dass man nichts lernen
kann
alles was ihr wissen müssen wir in frage
stellen als situatives oder
konstruiertes wissen natürlich sind das
wichtige analytische werkzeuge aber
schlussendlich der große
wissenschaftshistoriker bruno latour
schrieb in einem wunderbaren artikeln
er habe die wissenschaft massiv
kritisiert sie seien konstruiert und man
müsse sie in kulturellen kontext sehen
doch betreffend der klimaerwärmung habe
er nicht gesagt wir könnten nichts
lernen
ich habe nicht gesagt ihr könnt nicht
wissen dass der planet sterben hat es
gibt dinge die er ist also auch stick
und erzähle sie so dass man sie lesen
wird eine ganz kurze frage da kommen wir
zum ende leider wenn sie einem fremden
irland zeigen müssten sie können dann
ein ort gehen um ihm zu sagen dass er
die vereinigten staaten welchen ort
würden sie der wählen
lange stille das ist ja auch eine
antwort aber ja ich würde diese person
gettysburg das schlachtfeld des
amerikanischen bürgerkriegs zeigen wo
ich noch nie war das ist womöglich eine
schlechte antwort aber ich würde dort
auch etwas neues lernen
ok telefon ich würde gerne mal mit ihnen
nach gettysburg gehen würde ich
wahnsinnig viel erfahrung sowie dieses
gespräch auch eine war ich danke ihnen
sehr dass sie hat ihr mann
ich danke ihnen und jetzt gleich zeigt
die sternstunde kunst ein filmporträt
der französischen architekten und möbel
designerin charlotte perillo bleiben sie
also dran und denken sie weiter
[Musik]